chez nous quoi mon père pour rien les
autres n'ont qu'à travailler pour lui he
ça ton père ne fait rien enfin allez il
lit son journal travaille dans le jardin
enfin ce qu'il aime bien faire quoi
sinon le reste il s'en fout et ta mère
oh ma mère elle fait presque tout dans
la maison avec mes sœurs et moi c'est la
mère qui travaille et le père chez nous
au village en tout cas il y en a
beaucoup qui font qui sont comme ça quoi
et et plus tard toi lorsque tu seras
père de famille est-ce que tu auras
l'attitude de ton père ou tu essaias de
faire autre chose ENF on dit jour tel
père tel fils alors je sais pas quels
sont les défauts des grandes personnes
Catherine c'est qui ne comprennent pas
les enfants qui qui croient qu' qu' font
ça tout pour les embêter Claude
euh je trouve qu'il cri trop en nous
regardant et il ne regardent pas leur
jeunesse parce que ma mère elle dit
aussi qu'elle a toujours très très bien
réussi à l'école mais je suis pas sûr
que c'est vrai hein tu as déjà retrouvé
ces carnets de notes ah non ça ils se
sont perdus